volcanoes dark-themed skins
intergalactic law let's talk about
fortnight season six hello and welcome
to PlayStation granade I know it's been
a while since we looked at fortnight
together so let's put that right
I've been sifting through the countless
theory videos all about season six and
I've checked all the leaked files for
the next big update allowing me to put
together eight things you should know
about season six of fortnight battle
royale some of these are links which are
pretty reliable but nothing certain and
some of these are insane theories that
are surprisingly believable I'll time to
tamp each major leak and theory in the
comments below so you can jump around
and point your friends to the theories
that you agree with by the way if you'd
like more fortnight content on the
channel do me a favor and write granade
in the comments I'd appreciate it
let's do this let's go through what we
know 100% already by using the weekly
loading screens to build a story after
the events of season 5 the rift
character was pulled back from our
reality along with the derp burger as
the week's continued the bright bomber
and her friends showed him around the
island as his costume upgraded suddenly
the rift in the sky created a cube in
the desert area of the map over time
this bad boy rolled around the map
changing the atmosphere in places by
week 7 the enforcers appeared which
going by the image scared the bejesus
out of our gang the following week
tomato town was gone replaced with
tomato temple and then in week 9 the
cube had finally caught up with the
group who couldn't help but touch it
Breck's in particular found out the hard
way
now the week 10 loading screen has been
revealed it opens up such possibilities
for fortnight here we see the bright
bomber touching the cube but look at her
reflection there's a negative version of
her looking back her eyes appear to be
covered in the rift lightning but the
most interesting thing here is her shirt
the happy-go-lucky llama is replaced
with a dragon let's quickly copyright a
name for her bright bomber could become
the dark destroyer no that sounds like
an adult movie star moving on
and now we can't adapt to speculate the
widely accepted theory is based around
the movement of the cube I'm sure you've
noticed the cube is going for a walk
around the map here cam even sure you've
deliberately crushed yourself with the
cube or murdered a few other players
with its force it's damn satisfying
isn't it
leakers have been able to plan out the
path of the cube and to this day they
have been spot on the cubes endpoint is
almost certain to be loot lake in terms
of law and backstory the cube looks to
feed from water and has regularly
crushed the stream about three times
before hitting the lake and now here's
where the fun begins in the data files
assets have been discovered that show
the introduction of lava to the map and
it's in the same shape has loved lake
leading many to believe the lake of
water will become a lake of lava and the
volcano will leap from that lava to
signify the start of season 6 here's
where it gets a little bit more
realistic
did you ever fly over loot Lake in week
1 of season 5 did you notice there's
something under the water could this be
that volcano I remember playing that
week and I was certain it would be a
pyramid like those found in Egypt keep
that in mind because I'm going to come
back to it later using the battle pass
we can grab a few clues and early fall
shadowing and even some aspects of law
the Restless skin was teased in the
battle past before it's released and so
was the shark with the laser on its head
and even the sushi themed characters -
there's an image of pizza Pete who gets
his own piece of lore in a moment but
right now I want to look at the first
spray paint called crazy castle a castle
in fort night is already a thing in save
the world back in the Halloween event
last year we looked for Dracula in a
dark themed Transylvanian area it was so
damn good on top of that we already have
three medieval skins including the
sacred Dark Knight and at present they
don't have anywhere to live I personally
thought the cube would create a castle
absolute lake complete with a moat which
would be crossable via a bridge or maybe
a grappling hook and guess what the
grappling hook was added a few weeks
after I thought that what do you think
am i onto something or would you prefer
a lava lake how about a castle on a lava
lake
she is all that sounds good let's go
back to the skin and locked off for
season five the enforcer what did you
think to it I have to admit I was
massively letdown although I do like the
riot shield and that riot shield made me
think that maybe the enforcers were
intergalactic time cops who were here to
put the riffs and portals back in check
what do you think I looked into this
theory and found an anonymous leaker on
reddit who said this about the enforcer
law the enforcers are the ones who sent
the cube the enforcers can't live in
Earth's atmosphere so they must change
it the cube creates small domes that
mimic their planet's atmosphere
absolute Lake the cube will absorb water
and send energy to the domes making them
grow season five will end with loot lake
drained and domes becoming twice as
large the trailer for season six will
show people walking up to the cube and
getting struck and bounded away drift
walks up to the cube and when the
lightning strikes him he doesn't get
knocked back because he's human the cube
keep striking him and the bolts gets
bigger drift becomes charged and the
cube explodes how cool does that sound
I'd I'd go with that I'm good with that
yep go with Epic Games what do you think
this leaker went on to say some
absolutely ridiculous things but the
more I look into them the more they make
sense stating the wailing woods bunker
will finally open the person inside
decides to follow his dream building a
chicken restaurant one of the battle
past skins is a restaurant mascot the
restaurant expands into an amusement
park throughout the season completely
replacing wailing woods right I know
that's completely far-fetched but let's
look at the evidence back in season four
the three items that vanished from the
world were all restaurant related first
the der burger which came back with the
rift character then the tomato head
which has just returned from a visit to
the Mayans by the looks of things and
the one we all forget is noms which
reappeared in the northeast corner of
the map not too far from that bunker
what if these three restaurant chains
are gearing up for World War three the
biggest food fight in history one from
the future one from present-day and
from the past it's a bit of a stretch
but I think it's plausible why do you
think I'm off my rocker let me know your
thoughts let's break that down a little
bit let's take the tomato head part of
that theory by now you'll only just be
able to remember tomahto town to meet a
mate old town however you choose to say
it it's caught with me the location was
pretty terrible with only a few chests
and terrible sight lines this was
improved dramatically with the addition
of tomato temple and the battle pass
image of pizza Pete has won reddit user
verb 73 craft excited and able to build
law around this occurrence here's what
he said about a time-traveling cult I'm
sure you all know Uncle Pete aka the
tomato has returned to his home in
tomato town however not in his former
glory his massive metallic structure
reduced to a measly carved rock many
have joked that he was burned due to the
rocks charcoal color but I think I have
a better idea
the Pete that returned is not the Uncle
Pete that left it's a replica an idol
carved by humans in the past as we've
seen in the update various items from
our reality have appeared such as drift
and the ATK's from the modern era
however we've also received a Viking
boat Easter Island heads and a variety
of other time periods my theory is that
whilst the cracks brought things from
different time periods it also sent
things to different time periods in the
case of Uncle Pete he might have been
sent back to the Stone Age causing
people at the time to believe he was a
God in fear of admiration said in
context they made idols of him and one
of them were sent back to the original
Pete's location only a week later tamato
temple appeared which really does
justify that story so well played Ferb
impressive work Ferb's theory also links
into character upgrades with skins
evolving I won't lie I do not like the
skin so I didn't buy it so I've been
unable to try the skin of great
challenges but if I can upgrade my
brighter bomber into a dark destroyer
I'd be all over that
[Music]
let's go back to leaks rather than
theories a leaker named Internet Adam
right name by the way
predicted the destruction of moisty Maya
and dusty Depot sadly he was sued for
leaking information by Epic Games
because he wasn't fact a games tester
hired to find bugs well one of his
friends named Internet Explorer
announced he was the real leaker and
told us information about season 5 some
were spot on and some seemed a little
off but what if everything he said was
true just not confined to season 5 let's
break it down he said there will be
dinosaurs they did appear didn't they
but not in the way we hoped other things
he said that didn't come true yet
include the motel becoming a wild west
saloon with animals nearby under train -
holy [ __ ] Batman how cool does that
sound
he's another leaker that also said a
theme park was coming to fortnight
leading back into what we've already
said earlier in addition he leaked the
information of an Egyptian structure
above loot Lake such as a pyramid which
many of us thought we already saw in
loot lake and even a sphinx
who needs history class let's play
fortnight instead other things he said
include a pirate Point area with Jack's
barrel style characters in the battle
pass and this sexy skin for tier 100 and
even a castle area replacing lucky
landing again these did not happen yet
the thing I really want to look at here
is that his constant reference is to
animals stating animals will be added
into the Battle Royale universe this now
looks increasingly likely thanks to
another leaker who looked into the
game's files and found a folder named
pets oh my goodness that sounds epic
epic imagine running around with a
palico from Monster Hunter I personally
want a hamster in a ball
come on epic if you're listening make it
so
to finish let's look at save the world
and the promise that it would appear for
free to battle royale players save the
world will indeed become free-to-play
but the issue of giving away free v
bucks to users will probably see the
free version released without the v book
challenges to make a big deal of going
free to play epic have hinted at save
the world skins coming to battle royale
so if you've unlocked some thick skins
keep all of them they may be worth more
than you know and those with the
founder's packs and higher imagine
bringing your $100 Bruce Lee Kill Bill
skin into Battle Royale
that would be pretty awesome and if
there's any excuse to bring my llama
headed ninja into battle royale I'll do
it all right people let's search this
dump and get out of here ASAP finally
season six has been delayed a little at
least an extra week which may see it
beginning on October rather than
mid-september as planned
out of everything you've seen what are
you hoping is true for me I want a
castle I want to pet hamster and maybe a
cowboy costume to wear on the weekend
you know I imagine from Playstation
grenade I'd love to know your thoughts
below it's been a pleasure it feels good
to be back on fortnight I'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]